this is Barry Jacobs from the
Netherlands and he has a big catapult
it's made from 100 foot high cranes and
what is very intent to launch from this
beast just himself
this guy has definitely taken 114
science fair he's put himself on the
line his own safety his own life to test
out a human catapult
[Music]
that's very hot just read the laws of
physics guys you don't have to feel it
in your body and almost die so how
exactly has Barry used physics to become
a flying dutchman so this isn't like a
bungee jump or an elastic catapult this
is a solid rope fixed in place with
weights hanging off the end they have a
huge amount of potential energy stored
in these heavy weights on one side of
the catapult and they're converting that
into kinetic energy which has to be
transferred to a very small mass of the
person being flung in the air okay but
what exactly are those so these guys
have created a pulley system with a
ratio of 1 to 16 that means when the
heavy weight drops one meter or one foot
the other side of the rope goes up 16
meters or 16 feet which means in the
time it takes for that to drop two
meters he's moved 32 meters so you can
see how he could be moving so quickly
as soon as the weight drops Barry's
catapulted 70 stories into the air
reaching speeds of around 160 miles an
hour that's more than an astronaut feels
taking off in a rocket
but as the old saying goes what goes up
must come down and ferry was high enough
that he needs a parachute to make terra
firma you got to ask yourself why do
they do it they do it for the women